do you like Elvis
what if I told you you are Elvis I am
Elvis this ancient Roman coin is Elvis
and you're about to find out why rock
star it's now or never
fact anyone who does not love does not
know God because God is love first John
4 8.
Elvis Presley
was a hunka Hunk of Burning Love
Burning Love foreign
[Music]
image of God
so God created man in his own image in
the image of God he created him male and
female he created them
Elvis was born poor but he was blessed
with a voice like a chorus of angels a
face that looked like it was carved by
Michelangelo a knack for shaking his
hips that would make cardi B sign up for
lessons and a love of rhinestones that
was rivaled only by his love of fried
peanut butter and banana sandwiches
so much Charisma such an amazing ability
to draw from or steal from depending on
your perspective various musical genres
such an Unstoppable fire hose of Gold
Records he's still the best-selling solo
music artist of all time and yet
they're just 42 years old he died on a
toilet
picture this the Graceland Mansion Elvis
is sitting on the kingly throne in his
bathroom reading a book titled a
scientific search for the face of Jesus
it's about the Shroud of Turin claimed
by some to be the burial cloth of Jesus
Elvis dies while reading about the image
of Jesus
what happens then allow me to
demonstrate
Elvis who just wants to be your teddy
bear dies and his fat bloated body falls
forward but remains folded in the basic
seated position
the king of rock and roll was found face
down butt up on the bathroom floor he
had 14 drugs in his system
pretty humiliating way to go a graceless
Death at a place called Graceland
what happened to Elvis and I don't mean
what happened at the surface level that
part's easy famous rock star needs some
pills to go to sleep some more pills for
energy to go on stage he builds up a
tolerance so he needs more and more and
more and more he's the most famous
person in the world so who's going to
tell him to stop whatever you say Elvis
whatever you say Elvis
next thing you know after being
prescribed more than 10 000 doses of
Narcotics amphetamines and sedatives
just in the first eight months of 1977
his fiancee finds his dead body with his
big round pale butt sticking straight up
in the air
and it was a blue Christmas the
Heartbreak Hotel
that's all pretty straightforward but
that's just the surface level what's
really going on here
how can someone so obviously born for
greatness be so thoroughly disgraced
demeaned degraded and why do we see this
happen over and over again
and am I really talking about you and me
even though I'm talking about Elvis
let's take a look
several months ago a movie about Elvis
came out with Austin Butler as Elvis and
Tom Hanks as Elvis's Dirtbag manager
Colonel Tom Parker
there's an interesting scene early in
the film a 19 year old Elvis is about to
go on stage after his first local hit
song and he's terrified in real life
Elvis never got over his stage fright
even after years of Performing people
would ask him why he was nervous about
going on stage they'd say how come you
never get used to the crowd and he would
reply it's always a different crowd
so at 19 he was scared to death and
nauseous and worried that he was going
to forget the words in the movie his mom
and dad and a few others sing a
Christian song with him to calm him down
they sing the 1950s white people version
of I'll Fly Away it's a nice soft sweet
song
then we get a flashback to Elvis's
childhood Elvis and some friends looked
through a hole in the wall at Arthur
crudup aka Big Boy cred up singing and
playing guitar Elvis hears the music and
he sees how the music affects the ladies
but then Elvis and his friends head over
to a Christian Revival service where
they're singing the most epic version of
I'll Fly Away in the history of church
services
[Applause]
Elvis sneaks into the service to see
what's going on one of his friends tries
to pull him back out but the pastor
won't let him
nope
in that revival tent young Elvis
encounters the spirit of the almighty
and he starts dancing he was drawn to
the tent by the music and the music
lifts him into the presence of God
and then we get this awesome scene where
the film goes back and forth between
Elvis shaking as a boy at the Revival
meeting and Elvis shaking as a 19 year
old as he's getting ready to go on stage
at the Louisiana hayride
the impression you get is that in
addition to Elvis's natural talents and
abilities he gets some special spiritual
anointing that allows him to move people
with his music but also that in Elvis's
mind the different ways you can move
people with music are all jumbled
together
so you can sing a song and people start
shaking you can sing a different song
and ladies start shaking something else
you can sing a song and get people to
praise God you can also sing a song and
get ladies to throw their panties on
stage
it's the same ability but you've got a
choice you can use your gift to get
whatever you want so what do you want
presence of God or panties flying at
your face
some of you perverts are thinking I'd go
with the panties a path that leads to
death on a toilet
that's the path Elvis ended up choosing
at the Louisiana hayride at first Elvis
didn't even understand what these young
ladies were screaming about his
bandmates told him it was because of the
way he wiggled and they said he should
do it more
and very quickly Elvis learned that his
Wiggles Amplified the impact of the
music it made the ladies want to rip his
clothes off to get a better look at
whatever was wiggling
now Elvis ended up using his gifts to do
all kinds of things he's saying gospel
songs he inspired people he drew
attention to people who were suffering
in the ghetto
he helped people he brought people
together he had endless piles of money
thrown at him and had endless piles of
panties thrown at him he did it all
and he did it his way
[Music]
he kept doing it his way until he was
found dead on the bathroom floor
literally mooning the world that
worshiped him with a big stamp on his
rear end that said Return to Sender
after years of being simultaneously
exalted and degraded idolized and
demonized after having all the money and
fame and women and drugs a rock star
could ever dream of
Elvis wanted to see the face of Christ
what happened to that man
the answer lies in this coin
this is a Roman Daenerys I bought this
from a shop in Jerusalem when my wife
and I were in Israel back in 2019 it's a
Denarius of Tiberius Caesar second
emperor of the Roman Empire Tiberius was
emperor during the public ministries of
John the Baptist and Jesus the Tiberius
Denarius is nicknamed the tribute Penny
because this was the coin that Jesus
referred to in a discussion about Jews
paying taxes to the Romans in Matthew
22. let's read the passage
then the Pharisees went out and laid
plans to trap him in his words they sent
their disciples to him along with the
herodians teacher they said we know that
you are a man of integrity and that you
teach the way of God in accordance with
the truth you aren't swayed by others
because you pay no attention to who they
are tell us then what is your opinion is
it right to pay the Imperial tax to
Caesar or not
this is a brilliant trap
[Applause]
if Jesus says yes it's right to pay
tribute to the Romans many Jews would be
angry at him for promoting allegiance to
their oppressors
but if he says no it's wrong to pay
tribute to the Romans the Romans would
be angry at him for promoting Rebellion
against the empire either way Jesus
would be in trouble
watch how he answers but Jesus knowing
their evil intent said you Hypocrites
why are you trying to trap me show me
the coin used for paying the tax
they brought him a Denarius and he asked
them whose image is this and whose
inscription
Caesar's they replied then he said to
them so give back to Caesar what is
Caesar's and to God what is God's
when they heard this they were amazed so
they left him and went away
so Jesus escapes the Trap
but it's easy to miss the point he was
making give to Caesar what is Caesar's
what should you give to Caesar
you should give Caesar that which Bears
His Image I.E this coin
give to God what is God's what should
you give to God
that which Bears His Image I.E you
in other words you're worried about
whether you should give this little
piece of silver to Caesar it's got his
image on it give it back to him if he
wants it
isn't there something much more valuable
that you should be concerned about
shouldn't you instead be focusing on
giving yourself to God why are you more
worried about the coin than you are
about yourself
get it
good because we're not done you can't
see this coin very well from there so
let's get a close-up
here's a Denarius it Bears the image of
Tiberius Caesar in the ancient world
Kings would put statues of themselves in
various parts of Their Kingdoms the
image of the King was supposed to be a
reminder of the king's Authority
not surprisingly when governments
started issuing coins they put images of
kings and sometimes of Queens on the
coins so people carried around reminders
of who's in charge in their pockets
now without something to compare this
coin to you wouldn't know if it's a
really nice coin or a terrible coin so
here's another Tiberius Denarius this
one makes the first one look good by
comparison because apart from a few
identifying features you can barely tell
what this coin is
it's almost completely lost its image
here's a really really nice Tiberius
Denarius this is graded as Choice
uncirculated
for whatever reason it was never passed
around it was never spent
I paid a lot of money for this one just
to make this simple point for you
notice the choice uncirculated coin is
bigger than the other two
why are they smaller
well keep in mind these are made of
silver so it was very common in the
Roman world to practice what's called
clipping
you get paid at Daenerys for your day's
work you take it to buy some groceries
for your family but before you give the
coin to the checkout girl you pull out a
small file and file off a little bit of
the silver you put the filings in a bag
and then use your Denarius to pay for
your groceries
if you keep doing this with every
Denarius you get you eventually have a
bag of silver shavings and that's worth
some money
that's why the circulated coins are
smaller than the uncirculated coin
so what does any of this have to do with
Elvis I'm glad you asked this Denarius
is like a young Elvis it's got the image
of the King on it but it's not perfect
as much as we'd like to think we're
perfect When We're Young we definitely
don't image God perfectly we don't know
what we're doing Elvis wasn't perfect
even when he was young he was an
imperfect image of God
as life goes on for Elvis people keep
taking little pieces of him like girls
ripping off his clothes
everyone takes a piece of Elvis until by
the time he's 42 younger than I am he's
barely recognizable he still has a great
voice but he's physically and mentally
breaking down
so what's this coin
this coin is like Jesus Jesus is the
perfect image of God all human beings
are created in the image of God but
there are two main components to being
the image of God one God creates us with
certain gifts so that we have the
ability to image or reflect God we have
the ability to make the invisible God
visible on Earth
two how we use these gifts is up to us
we can use our god-given abilities to
image God or we can use them for other
things we can even use them to degrade
ourselves and others
quite frequently we don't image God
properly we don't make the invisible God
visible on Earth instead we use our
god-given abilities to try to keep God
invisible on Earth
when you do that you're still the image
of God
but you're the Devil in Disguise too
that's where Christ comes in Christ the
perfect image of God the one who truly
made God visible on Earth restores our
relationship with God and by looking to
Christ and imitating Christ we grow in
our ability to image God
check out two short passages about this
second Corinthians 4. and even if our
gospel is veiled it is veiled to those
who are perishing in their case the God
of this world has blinded the minds of
the unbelievers to keep them from seeing
the light of the Gospel of the glory of
Christ who is the image of God
for what we Proclaim is not ourselves
but Jesus Christ as Lord with ourselves
as your servants for Jesus sake for God
who said let light shine out of Darkness
has shown in our hearts to give the
light of the knowledge of the glory of
God in the face of Jesus Christ
God gives us the light of the knowledge
of the glory of God in the face of Jesus
Christ
you'll recall that Elvis died reading a
book about the face of Jesus Christ
and Colossians 3 do not lie to one
another seeing that you have put off the
old self with its practices and have put
on the new self which is being renewed
in knowledge after the image of its
creator
here there is not Greek and Jew
circumcised and uncircumcised barbarians
scythians slave free but Christ is all
and in all
we are being renewed in knowledge after
the image of our creator
so in terms of our three coins young
Elvis is the imperfect image of God he
has amazing talent he has the ability to
image God in all of the relevant ways
but without the knowledge of Christ
without the knowledge of what it means
to image god Elvis doesn't image God
very well the world and its systems
degrade the image of God everyone takes
a piece of Elvis giving us a damaged
mangled almost unrecognizable Elvis
in Christ we see what it means to image
God perfectly
what should Elvis have done he should
have used his gifts to be more like
Christ
think about Elvis's fans
screaming trying to grab him even
throwing their panties at him
what were they drawn to
they were drawn to the amazing abilities
he was given
Elvis as the image of God was supposed
to be like a mirror that's at a 45
degree angle so that it reflects upwards
when his fans looked at him
and witnessed him using his gifts he was
supposed to remind them of the Almighty
he was supposed to make them look up
as he once looked up and as he
eventually tried to do again
what happens when someone like Elvis
with all his gifts his looks his
Charisma his Golden Voice his sideburns
his Blue Suede Shoes doesn't Point
people to the Almighty
he becomes an idol an object of worship
he takes the gifts that were given to
him so that he could Point people to God
and uses them to point people to himself
it didn't matter who was in the room
with Elvis all eyes were on Elvis
but when all eyes are on you
when you're the ultimate Idol
the world is going to notice when you
die on a toilet
just so you know I'm not really making
fun of Elvis for the way he died I might
die on a toilet you might die on a
toilet if old age doesn't get us some
disease or accident or Ax Murderer will
there are all kinds of ways to die some
of them are embarrassing
but think about this
Jesus died a humiliating death he was
beaten spit on paraded through the
streets and nailed to a cross he was
hanging there naked and bloody for hours
as people mocked and laughed
sounds much much worse than dying on a
toilet and yet we remember those two
deaths very differently
why is the humiliating death of Jesus so
incredibly different from the
humiliating death of Elvis
well when you're Imaging God as you
should
the world can do its absolute worst and
you'll still be pointing people to God
crucifixion was designed to be the most
horrifying way to execute someone
imaginable
Jesus imaged God so perfectly that 2 000
years later we sing songs about the
cross because of the one who was nailed
to it
no one will ever sing songs about
Elvis's toilet
I said in the beginning that you are
Elvis that I am Elvis
because his talents and abilities were
so visible so famous Elvis was just a
more conspicuous version of what we all
are
all created in God's image we're all
given abilities that we're supposed to
use to image God the world and its
systems strive to dismantle us piece by
piece so that we don't image God as we
should
Jesus shows us how to image God to the
fullest
like Elvis you've got a gift
and you've got a choice
when you're using your gift people might
notice
but don't use your gift to make yourself
an idol
as Paul says in First Corinthians 4 what
do you have that you didn't receive
why are you boasting as if you're the
source of greatness
so when you use your gift and when that
attention comes be ready
decide in advance how you're going to
react
nice try
it's okay she's my wife
ever since the world began am I right
[Music]